[Music]
kovid 19 has ripped through
india leaving horror and heartbreak in
its wake
officially the virus has killed 400 000
indians but the real death toll is
thought to be much higher
the race is on to vaccinate the country
though not everyone is convinced
the government needs to tell us why we
should get it what are the benefits
they are failing to give us information
it's especially a problem in rural areas
where two-thirds of indians live
vaccine hesitancy is a major threat to
india's race
to beat the pandemic
[Music]
india's devastating second wave of
coronavirus infections appears to be
ebbing away
the focus now is on vaccinating as many
people as possible
to prevent a third one however in a
country as diverse as
india there remains a diversity of
opinion towards vaccinations
namisha jaiswal reports from the north
of the country
it's their turn to get vaccinated
and these young residents of rohitak in
the north indian state of haryana
have been eagerly waiting for it after a
month of low vaccine availability
supply is finally catching up with the
demand here
officials say online slots in the small
city are booked quickly
and allowing offline registrations in
june has improved access to the jab even
further
doctors believe india's massive second
wave
could have erased vaccine hesitancy
after the second wave people are
scrambling to get vaccinated
they say please vaccinate us we
definitely want protection from this
virus
i believe vaccine hesitancy is
negligible
in a village 20 kilometers from the
hospital
these men paint a very different picture
only two of them have been vaccinated
because they volunteered in the vaccine
trials
and even they don't feel confident about
the benefits of the vaccine
in the last two months more than 50
people have died in this village
these men say it wasn't the corona virus
that killed them
but fear even doctors have died after
vaccinations
there was a vaccine they recalled i
think now they are saying plasma therapy
isn't useful
they just keep changing their stance
people aren't afraid the air is clean
here the problem is in the cities
because of the air
they're felling trees it's a city
problem it is in the villages
the village's local health center wears
a deserted look
all year only 600 people have been
vaccinated
supplies are limited and there isn't a
rush anywhere
and it's all the more reason that the
few who do show up
stand out sunil bhardwaj traveled here
from a nearby village to get his father
the second dose
many people worry about fevers after the
vaccine my father had one
too but i got it as well and i had no
side effects at all
the vaccine is very important everyone
must get it
bhardwaj may be a lone voice here right
now
but he's emphatic he tells everyone
around him
that the vaccine can save lives
india is slowly solving its supply
crisis
but it may face an uphill battle against
skepticism
to prevent a crisis of demand as well
well let's speak to anway shaduta who is
a senior researcher at the christian
mickelson
institute thanks for joining us on the
covid 19 special can you just explain to
us
how governments in india are trying to
tackle the challenge of vaccine
hesitancy
thanks rob for that question and thank
you for having me on the show
but as we know vaccine hesitance in
itself is a very complex phenomenon and
we even see the whole anti-vaxxer
movement
in the global north where people are
much more educated so clearly education
is not a reason that makes people take
vaccination or not
now coming to india we see more
hesitancy in rural areas
as opposed to urban areas and there are
several causes to that
and very briefly let me touch upon those
so first being in rural areas
historically there has been an
aversion towards western allopathic
medication
and as opposed to urban areas where
people have had more access to health
care to begin with and that's allopathic
health care
now add to this makes other factors like
religion
caste gender so for example there's been
a lot of hesitation amongst the muslim
community because they feel that there
is big fat in the vaccination or the
jain community in
india who think that the vaccination is
not vegetarian or the hindu community
who might think there is cow serum in
the vaccination
we also see that the vaccination rates
are higher amongst
men and then women given that it's a
patriarchal society
as well and finally added to that
are various other factors like mistrust
in the state
itself and also if we see
india has been very successful in its
polio vaccination program
but those are catered to children and
not necessarily adults
so all of this i think makes uh vaccine
hesitancy a very
complex problem and how is the indian
state dealing with it
so off late they have uh brought
together a lot of religious leaders
and they are making these religious
leaders appeal to their own communities
and talk to them
and to persuade them there have been
celebrities going on tv or local
politician
because there is also this neighborhood
effect so if someone in your locality
gets the vaccine
and you are more likely to take it so
those are the some of the
um uh uh yeah i mean the big issue is
diversity right i mean india is
an enormous country with enormous amount
of diversity you've talked about the
different things uh
you know in terms of you know city and
rural but also
religious groups how do you go about
tackling a pandemic in a in a
coordinated way when there's so much
difference
within the different areas
i think it has been a major challenge
and we can see the state kind of failed
especially um to contain the second wave
of the pandemic
and the part of that also rests in not
being prepared for what was coming
now how do you tackle it something that
really worked in india in some states as
opposed to other
so let's take kerala for example a state
that managed to curb this
um or contain or manage or govern the
pandemic very well
as opposed to one of the most populated
states in the world uttar pradesh
and what explains this are historical
investments
into decentralizing local governments
into building health care and other
infrastructures
which necessarily did not happen in case
of uttar pradesh due to say corruption
due to other political factors that have
been at play
and therefore is this about tailored
approaches to
two different areas is that what you
mean by the decentralization
yeah so decentralization means where you
decentralized
power to up to the local level and you
give say in indian case the panchayat
the local
governing bodies uh amount of powers
and resources to govern because they are
the last
leg of delivery of services to the
people in the
most remote rural areas and therefore
the management should have been
kind of top uh bottom up rather than you
know
complete top down and so we see a
diversity of responses and of course
within that we have to feature for
other social uh political uh stratifiers
as i mentioned before
is there anything that we've seen during
the second wave in india that leaves you
thinking
that a third wave can be prevented
so yeah a couple of things firstly i
think we have learned that we should not
already accept victory over a virus
which is still ongoing
we need to be more prepared and not
dismantle health care infrastructure and
other infrastructure facilities
and particularly we need to take into
account for example the migrant crisis
that affected the first wave
so that it could not have happened much
in the second wave so
taking into consideration the most
vulnerable groups and um
and so that in a third wave these
communities can be protected and there
can be more preparedness
anointing from the christian mickelson
institute thanks for joining us on the
coveted 19 special
thank you so much and now it's the part
of the program where we put one of your
questions to our science correspondent
derek williams
i had my second dose of synovac a week
ago
but i also want to get a vaccine
certified by the who and eu
how long should i wait since this
question came in the vaccine
made by cynovac which which is called
the vero
cell vaccine it's received an
emergency use listing from the who
though
it's still under review at the european
medicines agency but i
i still want to look at this topic
because i receive
questions like this one all the time um
that's down to the fact that that in
trials
inactivated virus vaccines made by
chinese manufacturers had lower
efficacy numbers than for example
approved messenger rna vaccines
and there are also now some doubts about
how well they work against the delta
variant of sars
cov2 so so let's look at what the
experts are saying so far
about getting booster shots with the
second type of vaccine
after being vaccinated at least once
with another mixing and matching is
already going on
with different vaccine platforms um big
clinical studies looking at a range of
combinations of different vaccines
are progressing pretty quickly and there
don't seem to be any big
red flags so far um when it comes
to safety many experts believe that
mixing and matching even within the
two-dose regime that most vaccines
require
that that might actually turn out to be
more effective
at preventing covet 19 than
two doses of the same vaccine so
i don't think anyone is expecting that a
third booster shot
with a different vaccine would cause
major problems
in a couple of persian gulf nations for
example they've already begun
giving a third pfizer biotech booster
to some high-risk people who were fully
vaccinated
with a sino-farm vaccine more than six
months ago
the w.h.o however still hasn't made any
concrete recommendations
you